enormes llamas devorando el icónico
parque nacional de yosemite y el bosque
nacional de la sierra los bomberos
dijeron que las altas temperaturas la
baja humedad y la vegetación totalmente
seca dificultan la lucha contra las
llamas el sábado más de 6000 personas
estaban bajo órdenes de evacuación
la electricidad había sido cortada a más
de 2.000 hogares y negocios
vinieron hace unos 15-20 minutos y nos
dijeron que todo el mundo tiene que irse
sobre las cuatro se cortó la
electricidad y el fuego se ha ido
acercando a nosotros cada vez más rápido
espero que sean capaces de sacarlo antes
de que dañe la casa de alguien pero esto
no tiene buena pinta
el incendio comenzó el viernes y su
causa sigue siendo investigada 400
bomberos están en el lugar y
describieron el fuego como explosivo y
extremo esperan que se tarde una semana
en contener las llamas ya que las
temperaturas récords seguirán siendo
altas durante los próximos días en
california pero también en todo el país
amenazando algunos de los árboles de
secuoya gigantes más antiguos del mundo
y su ecosistema los servicios forestales
de eeuu han anunciado que tomarán
medidas de emergencia para salvarlos
despejando bajo los arbustos y cortando
árboles más pequeños para reducir la
densidad en los parques en un intento de
contener las llamas y prevenir futuros
incendios